[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهده في الوقت الذي
احدثكم في احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه
من النيابه عاصمه النيجر تحديدا من ساحه
التشاور نرصد المشهد بعد اعلان قاده
الانقلاب نقل الجوي امام جميع الطائرات
حتى اشعار اخر
الى واشنطن حيث اعلن اعلن عن وصول اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف بحار امريكيين الى الشرق
الاوسط في اطار خطه لتعزيز الوجود العسكري
في المنطقه
من واشنطن الى نيويورك تحديدا مبنى الامم
المتحده حيث كشف المتحدث باسم المنظمه
الدوليه عن وصول اول قافله انسانيه الى
ولايه شرق دارفور منذ بدء الصراع في
السودان قبل اشهر
في مواضيع الحصاد
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي يؤكد للجزيره
اصرار واشنطن على اعاده النظام الدستوري
في النيجر قاده اكواس يعقدون قمه الخميس
لتحديد الخطوات التاليه بشان النيجر
وباريس تؤكد دعم الاتحاد الاوروبي لجهود
اكواس وقاده الانقلاب يعلنون اجراءات
امنيه ويحذرون من تدخل خارجي محتمل
تعزيزات بحريه امريكيه في الشرق الاوسط
واشنطن تعلن وصول اكثر من 3000 جندي اضافي
لحمايه الامن البحري الاقليمي من الانشطه
الايرانيه طهران تشدد على قدره دول
المنطقه حمايه امنها بنفسها والحرس الثوري
يلوح بالرد على اي تصعيد امريكي
وسط تصعيد ميداني كيف تقول ان قتلى وجرحى
سقطوا في قصف صاروخي لبدن سكني شرقي
اوكرانيا
الجيش الروسي يعلن تقدمه نحو كوبيانسك في
شمال شرق اوكرانيا
واوكرانيا تواصل استهداف العمق الروسي
الجيش السوداني يكثف قصفه في ام درمان
مستهدفا مواقع للدعم السريع مصادر تتحدث
عن محاولته السيطره على جسر الشامبات
الواصل بين ام درمان والخرطوم بحري وخط
الامداد الرئيسي لقوه الدعم والدعم السريع
يرد بقصف مواقع في المدينه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه تجدد يوميا
تتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوريا
تتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
في الحلقه الاحدث لاجراءات بريطانيه مثيره
للجدل طالبوا لجوء يستقلون على سفينه
راسيه في جنوب غرب انجلترا
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه في مقابله
خاصه مع الجزيره انما يجري في النيجر
يعتبر عرقله لنظام الدستوري واضاف بلينكن
انه على اتصال وثيق مع رئيس النيجر محمد
باسوم والعديد من القاده الافارقه
لاستعاده النظام الدستوري في البلاد
ما رايناه في النيجر هو عرقله لنظام
الدستوري ونحن كالعديد من البلدان في جميع
انحاء افريقيا وعلى وجه الخصوص المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا مصممون على
اعاده النظام الدستوري للنيجر وهذا ما
يركز عليه الجميع الان لذلك كنت على اتصال
وثيق بالرئيس بازون ومع العديد من القاده
في جميع انحاء افريقيا والجميع يعمل نحو
نفس الهدف وهو استعاده النظام الدستوري
وكان المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
ماثيو ميلر قد قال ان بلاده علقت مساعدات
تقدر بمئات الملايين من الدولارات للنيجر
اثر الانقلاب الاخير واضاف خلال مؤتمر
صحفي ان عوده هذه المساعدات رهن بتنحي
قاده المجلس العسكري عن السلطه واعاده
نظام الدستوريه للبلاد
الوزير بلينكن اعلن الجمعه تعليقا مؤقتا
للمساعدات التي نقدمها للنيجر ويشمل هذا
التعليق مبالغ ضخمه من المساعدات
الانمائيه والامنيه المقدمه للحكومه في
النيجر واذا ما تنح قاده المجلس العسكري
عن السلطه واعادوا النظام الدستوريا
للبلاد فسنرفع التعليق ونعاود في اليوم
التالي تقديم هذه المساعدات وكما اوضحنا
فان مئات الملايين من الدولارات من
مساعداتنا للنيجر على المحك الان
وفي جديد التطورات اتخذ المجلس العسكري في
النيجر اجراءات امنيه في عموم البلاد
تزامنا مع قراره اغلاق المجال الجوي
يتزامن هذا مع مواصله مؤيدي المجلس
العسكري مظاهراتهم الداعمه لقراراته بينما
يطالب الحزب الحاكم ومناصره بعوده الرئيس
محمد بازوم الى السلطه وفي ظل الاوضاع
التي تمر بها النيجر تطالب احزاب وشخصيات
بارزه في البلاد المجلس العسكري بسرعه
تنظيم انتخابات رئاسيه
اجراءاتنا امنيه في شوارع النيجر تحسبا
لما ستسفر عنه مشاورات مجموعه بلدان غرب
افريقيا التي رفضت ما عقدم عليه قاده في
الجيش من تعليق للعمل بالدستور واطاحه
الرئيس
كما حددت باستخدام القوه العسكريه لاعاده
الرئيس بازون للسلطه
يستمر المناصرون للمجلس العسكري في
تاييدهم له ويرون في قاده المجلس مخلصين
لبلادهم من هيمنه قوى غربيه خاصه فرنسا
المستعمره السابقه لبلادهم
اليوم بلادنا بحاجه الى التحرير حاجتنا
الى التحرر ضروريه في الوقت الحاضر بعض
المناطق تواجه الارهاب بشكل كبير ما دفع
الناس الى المغادره ولذلك اناشد كل الشباب
الانضمام الينا
وفي حين يقول قاده المجلس العسكري ان
خطواتهم تحقق مطالب الشعب وتحظى بتاييده
تقف دول ضد اطاحه بازوم وتتحدث عن استعاده
المجلس العسكري
بمسلحي مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه لدعمه امنيا
وتوطيده في السلطه
احزاب وشخصيات بارزه في الساحه السياسيه
بالنيجر تدعو الى ان يمضي المجلس العسكري
سريعا في تنظيم انتخابات الرئاسيه
اما الحزب الحاكم ومناصريه فانهم يطالبون
بعوده بازون الفوريه الى السلطه حتى لو
تطلب الامر استخدام القوه الحزب الحاكم
اول موقفه على هذه الضغوطات واغلاق الحدود
والضغط الغربي
اتخذتها فرصه
لعوده النظام الشرعي للبلاد اما الشارع
فيامل الا تؤثر العقوبات التي فرضتها
بلدان غرب افريقيا وايقاف البلدان الغربيه
المساعدات عن النيجر في اقتصاد بلادهم
يتطلع السكان هنا
وغالبيتهم من الباحثين عن لقمه عيش الى
تجنب اثار الاضطرابات السياسيه والعسكريه
التي تعيشها النيجر خاصه بعد قرار المجلس
العسكري اغلاق المجال الجوي
وياملون وضع حد للنداءات التي ظلت بلادهم
تعاني منها طيله العقود الماضيه
فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره
والمحلله السياسي سيد عباس الى ماذا تؤشر
الاجراءات الامنيه التي اتخذها قاده
الانقلاب بعد انتهاء مهله اكواس
الصوت
ساعيد طرح السؤال سالتك نعم ساعيد السؤال
سالتك بعد انتهاء مهله اكواس الى ماذا
تؤشر الاجراءات الامنيه التي يتخذها قاده
الانقلاب في النيجر
اذا الان
بيدي يعني قاده الانقلاب للنيجر مصير دوله
النيجر عموما
فالنيجر الان او الشعب النيجري الان سلم
مسيره بيدي يعني القاده الانقلابيين فلذلك
خرجوا يعني بحشد غفير واعلنوا تشجيعهم
وكذلك اعلنوا يعني
وكذلك اعلنوا يعني رضاهم يعني بهذا يعني
هذا واضح بالمناسبه من خلال الصور ولكن
انا اسالك هل هل نزل قاده الانقلاب
يتخوفون من عمل عسكري محتمل في ظل
الاجراءات الامنيه التي يتخذونها منها
مثلا
تعليق الرحلات فوق النيجر مثلا
ايوه لازال هناك لماذا لانهم الان
عقلا و اغلاق
الجو المجال الجوي يعني
المحطه محطه الطيران ايوه اعلن ذلك فهذا
ان دل على شيء انما يدل على انهم يعني لا
زالوا يعني يتخذون حذرا ويتوقونه يعني
حيثما ياتوا في حيث ما ياتي ياتيهم ايوه
طيب
ما هو السيناريو او او الخطه الزمنيه التي
يضعها قاده الانقلاب للوصول الى النيجر
لاوضاع افضل مما كانت عليه ايام رئاسه
السيد بازون
ايوه اولا
اعلنوا يعني الانقطاع عن فرنسا هذا اول
شيء يعني وهذا الذي كل من النيجريين
ينتظره ايوه فاذا هذا وكذلك دوله مالي ثم
دوله بوركينا يعني هي
يعني قدوتهم في الامر اذا حيث اتجهت
الدوله مالي وكذلك حيث اتجهت الدوله
بوركينا فاذا هم ايضا سوف يتجهون هذا يعني
الاتجاه اذا كل ما تسير عليه دوله مالي
وكذلك دوله بوركينا فاسو فدوله النيجر
فقط مع فرنسا انهم معا الان دول افريقيه
تطالب بعوده الديمقراطيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
قطع المساعدات سمعنا قبل قليل بلنكن يقول
بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مصممه على
استعاده الحياه الديمقراطيه كيف سيواجه
قاده الانقلاب هذا الرفض الواسع الاقليمي
والدولي لانقلابهم
ايوه هذا يعني لا بد للعوده الى
الديمقراطيه لابد للاوده ولكن للاسف الوقت
الرائن الان
الهيئه العسكريه او السلطه العسكريه لابد
ان يدرسوا الواقعه وكذلك ينظر ريثما يعني
اذا تم الامور اذا استقرت الامور لابد لهم
يعني ان يقدموا او ان يعودوا الى النظام
يعني الديمقراطي هذا واجب وهذا لابد لا
محاله يعني في ذلك
وبالمناسبه فلذلك بعض من النيجيريين الان
يقولون لو لو لم يرسل يعني السيد بازون
تلك الرساله او تلك لما قال التي كتبها
ونشرها يعني على صفحته لو لم يعني يطلب من
الامريكا ان تساعده لو ترك الامر يعني
يسير هكذا بعد ما تستقر الامور اذا اعلنا
او اذا يعني انشا حزبه الخاص
فالنيجريين يعني ربما يكون معه شكرا لا
يكون وهذا ان دل على شيء انما يدل على ان
لابد يعني للعوده الى النظام الديمقراطي
الخامس الاكاديمي والمحلل السياسي شكرا لك
تنبيه لا تحليق في اجواءنا
يقولوها للعالم حكام النيجر الجدد اغلق
مجال البلاد الجوي وتوعدوا برد قوي وفوري
على كل مخالف تلك احدث قرارات قاده
الانقلاب في نيامي بعد تجاهلهم مهله
الاقواس للعوده الى المسار الدستوري
ثمه من عواصم العالم ما يعتقد مثل روما
انه ينبغي تمديد المهله الممنوحه لمجلس
النيجر العسكري ومنح الدبلوماسيه فرصه
وثمه ما يلوح مثل برلين بالعقوبات ضد
المجلس الثابت على موقفه منذ استلائه على
السلطه اواخر الشهر الماضي
فما الخطوه التاليه
المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
اكواس هي المعنيه بالسؤال ربما ياتي
الجواب من اجتماع قمه تستعد المجموعه
لعقده في ابوجا الخميس المقبل
يصعب تحديد ما اذا كانت فرضيه التداخل
العسكري في النيجر قد تجاوزتها الاحداث
غير ان رفاق الجنرال عبد الرحمن تشاني
يتاهبون لكل احتمال
تشير معلومات متطابقه بحوزتنا الى ان
اجنبيه تعد لمهاجمه النيجر وشعبه بالتنسيق
مع منظمه ومجموعات ارهابيه مسلحه ويحذر
المجلس الوطني لحمايه البلاد منظمه التي
تعمل لصالح تلك القوه الاجنبيه يحذرها من
مغبه اي تدخل في شؤون النيجر ومن النتائج
الوخيمه لاي مغامره عسكريه على امن منطقه
الساحل واستقرارها ووحدتها
يعتمد كل عمل عسكري وفقا للخبراء على
التحضير الجيد لكن مسؤولا في اكواس ذكر
لصحيفه
ان جيوش المنطقه يلزمها مزيد من الوقت
لتعزيز قوه الوحدات العسكريه قبل دخول
النيجر حتى الان يبدو الفرنسيون الاكثر
حماسه لتحرك من ذلك النوع ربما لخسارتهم
المحتمله حليفا اخر في القاره السمراء
رفعت باريس سقف تحذيراتها لمواطنيها
الباقين في النيجر وصنفت كل مناطق البلاد
حمراء اما اجراءاتها العقابيه فامتدت من
ساحه انقلاب الاحداث في افريقيا الى ابرز
داعمه في الجوار
لا يخفي القاده العسكريون في مالي
وبوركينا فاسو دعمهم لخطوات نظرائهم في
المجلس العسكري بالنيجر بل واستعدادهم
للقتال الى جانبهم اذا استهدفهم عمل عسكري
خارجي
لذلك واكثر علقت باريس مساعداتها لبوركينا
فاسو بكل اشكالها اما الخطوط الجويه
الفرنسيه فلا رحلات لها ستقلع باتجاه
باماكو ووجدو حتى يوم الجمعه المقبل
العقيده المتقاعد فيستوس ابو عجي المستشار
الامني السابق للمجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول
غرب افريقيا اكواس العقيد فيستوس هل تعتقد
ان الخيار العسكري لا يزال مطروحا على
طاوله اكواس
شكرا لاستضافه
الى ان تقول اكواس للجمهور العالمي
بانها قد تراجعت عن خيار التدخل العسكري
مع بقايا على الطاوله ولكن لابد ان اشرح
ما اقصد ان
الجدول او المهن الزمنيه
في مثل هذه اوقات تختلف عن اوقات العاديه
لذلك فان السلطات
الاكواس قدمت انذارا قبل اسبوع وانتهى
بالامس ولكن ذلك لا يعني بالضروره ان اكوا
ستقوم بغزو
او اطلاق هجوم للتدخل العسكري التدخل
العسكري قد ياخذ وقتا طويلا وربما افضل
مثال في هذا هو
الوضع الذي فيك
اثناء الحرب الاهليه في ليبيريا عندما
قامت شاي ستيلر بغزو لابيريا حوالي شهر
1989 اكوا سقطت خيار الحوار والوساطه
لحوالي ثمانيه اشهر حتى شهر سبتمبر قبل
قبل ان تقوم مجموعه مراقبه نشرها
وبالتالي ذلك بوضوح في هذه الحاله ما
يتعلق بنيجيريا ان
السلطه كانت متسرعه قليلا فيك وهسه
باعلان عقوبات
وفي الوقت ذاته اصدرت انذارا وضعت خط
احمرا على الطاوله وخلال بضعته هيام
نجد نيجيريا ودول اخرى متغربه
افريقيا بداوا يهددون نيجيريا
ونيجيريا انها قامت بكذا وكذا اذا بعباره
اخرى لم افتحوا مجال الوساطه او الحوار
وفقط لجا الى خيار القوه كخيار الاول
واعتقد ان هذا سيخلق مشاكل كثيره لاخوان
امام هذا الواقع العقيد فسوس اذا سمحت لي
امان هذا الواقع بانه سيخلق مشاكل كبيره
لاكواس ما هي الحلول غير العسكريه التي
يمكن ان يطرحها اكواس لعوده الديمقراطيه
كما تطالب كثير من الدول في النيجر
كل الخيارات قد تكون محدوده لو اصغينا
بحرص لما قاله ارلون الوزير بلنكن فانه
تحدث
ولم يبدعوا اعاده محمد بازون الى السلطه
بل دعا الى استعاده الديمقراطيه وهذا لا
يعني بالضروره حتى لو كانت قد استعيدت ان
الديمقراطيه
تكون بدون بازوم وبالتالي هذا يتناقض بشكل
كبير مع موقف
التي تصر على ان ضروره عوده بازوم الى
منصبه فلو افترضنا انه قد عاد الى
لم يعد الى السلطه فعليك وستضطر الدخول في
حوار وما ينبغي ان تقوم به
ليس السنه الارسال وفود متشاهدون بنين
ونيجيريا تبعت واتحاد الاوروبي أبعث
وفد علينا ان نعزز جهودنا الدبلوماسيه
سؤال اريد اجابه مقتضبه امام هذا الواقع
الذي تفضلت به وقلت بانه ليس بالضروره
استعاده الديمقراطيه ليس بالضروره عوده
بازوم الى الى الحكم هل هل يبدو لكم قاده
الانقلاب بانهم على استعداد
لاجراءات سريعه لاعاده الديمقراطيه في
البلاد باقتضاب شديد لو سمحت
سوف لحد الان
منذ 23 الشهر يوليو تموز لا يبدو هذا
الحلق كذا
شرع ان
ان الاخوان عينوا ان القلابيين عينوا ضباط
عسكريين
مسؤولين عن الضواحي والمحافظات وهذا كله
لا يدل على انه مستعد لاي حلول وسط او
تنازلات او السماح لبازون بالعوده الى
منصبه وهم عودهم عودتهم الى
سكناتهم كلهم
شكرا لك العقيد متقاعد فيستوس ابو عجي
المستشار الامني السابق للمجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا اكواس
[موسيقى]
عززت الولايات المتحده وجودها العسكري في
الشرق الاوسط ونشرت قرابه ثلاثه الاف جندي
من البحريه ضمن الاسطول الخامس في خطوه
وضعها المتحدث باسم الاسطول بانها تعكس
التزام بلاده بالامن البحري الاقليمي وفي
رد فعل ايراني حذر الحرس الثوري من ان
توقيف او احتجاز اي سفينه ايرانيه من قبل
القوات الامريكيه سيقابل بالمثل
التوتر يخيم على ممرات تجاره النفط
استراتيجيه تزامنا مع سخونه في عدد من
مناطق العالم الولايات المتحده بدات تعزيز
وجودها العسكري في الممرات المائيه
الحيويه بالاعلان عن وصول اكثر من ثلاثه
الاف جندي من الاسطول الخامس الى الشرق
الاوسط ووفق اعلان رسمي لقياده الاسطول
فان الانتشار يؤكد التزام واشنطن القويه
والثابت بالامن البحري الاقليمي وتاتي في
اطار خطه لتعزيز الوجود العسكري لردع
النشاط المزعزع للاستقرار وتخفيف التوترات
الاقليميه بحسب المتحدث باسم الاسطول
الخامس
التعزيزات شملت السفينه الهجوميه
البرمائيه باتان القادره على حمل قرابه 20
طائره مقاتله وفرقاطات انزال برمائيه
وسفينه
اللتين دخلتا البحر الاحمر عبر قناه
السويس قادمتين من المتوسط وتشمل منطقه
عمليات الاسطول الامريكي الخامس نحو
مليونين وخمسمائه
تمتد من الخليج الى خليج عمان والبحر
الاحمر واجزاء من المحيط الهندي ونقاط في
مضيق هرمز وقناه السويس ومضيق باب المندب
الخطوه الامريكيه سبقتها تصريحات تحدثت عن
عزم واشنطن نشر جنود على متن سفن تجاريه
في مضيق هرمز ايران تقرا التحرك الامريكيه
على انه خطوه لمراقبه سير الملاحه في مضيق
هرمز استراتيجي ومياه الخليج وشمال المحيط
الهندي وحذرت الخارجيه الايرانيه من ان
الخطوه الامريكيه ستؤدي الى زعزعه الامن
والاستقرار
الوجود الامريكي في المنطقه لا يوفر الامن
بل سيؤدي الى زعزعه الامن والاستقرار فيها
نؤمن بان الدول المطله على الخليج الفارسي
وبحر عمان قادره على ضمان امن هذه المنطقه
بشكل جيد بينما قال الحرس الثوري ان توقيف
او احتجاز اي سفينه ايرانيه من قبل القوات
الامريكيه سيقابل بالمثل وكانت طهران كشفت
خلال الايام الماضيه عن صاروخي كروز
يوجهان بالذكاء الاصطناعي الى جانب مسيرات
وسفن مزوده بصواريخ يصل مداها الى الف
كيلو متر وبكتمال نشر الجنود ضمن الاسطول
الخامس سيشكلها هؤلاء قوه ارتكاز لاي مهمه
حراسه مسلحه في مضيق هرمز الذي يمر من
خلاله نحو 20% من النفط الخام العالمي
[موسيقى]
مونتانا ويليام القائد السابق للقياده
الوسطى للقوات الامريكيه ومن طهران محمد
مهدي شريعه مداريا الدبلوماسيه الايراني
السابق الادميرال
ما دواعي هذا
التوجه الامريكي ما يحصل في مضيق هرمز هل
يستدعي زياده
القوات الامريكيه في المنطقه
في البدايه نود ان نتاكد من اننا على نفس
الموجه بالنسبه الى هذه التعزيزات واشنطن
لقد اعلنت عن نشر لقوات المشاه البحريه
الامريكيه على سفن من ضمن البحريه
الامريكيه
وهذا هي عمليه سوف تحرك من خلالها الجنود
من منطقه البحر المتوسط الى تلك المنطقه
نتحدث عن عدد من المارينز او قوات مشاه
البحريه الامريكيه الذين ينتشرون في كل
اقطار العالم
[موسيقى]
في المنطقه لماذا يحصل ذلك اولا براي
استجابه على التصرفات الايرانيه بما في
ذلك عمليه احتجاز ناقلات النفط التجاريه
في منطقه الخليج وهذا يؤ الى عرقله
الملاحه الحره والتجاره واود ان اعلق ايضا
بالنسبه الى هذه النقطه بالعوده الى
التاريخ في السنوات القليله الماضيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قلصت بشكل
كبير تواجدها في منطقه الخليج وهو امر
ياتي ايضا
بتحركات تاتي للسفن وتذهب سفن اخرى ولكن
هناك مخاوف فالمنطقه بان الولايات المتحده
تخلت عن الاهتمام بمنطقه الخليج ولكن هذا
غير صحيح لانه من
مثلا من بين المهمات الاساسيه بالنسبه الى
قوات مشات البحريه والبحريه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي العمل في كل انحاء
العالم الانتشار والتموضع واعاده الانتشار
في مناطق مختلفه في هذه الحاله السيد محمد
مهدي شريعه مداري في طهران لنفهم كيف ترى
طهران زياده التواجد العسكري في في هذه
المنطقه التي تنشط فيها قوه الحرس الثوري
الايراني
اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
ولمشاهدي قناه الجزيره اولا هذا ليس امرا
جديدا منطقه الخليج الفارسي شهدت تواجد
قوات عسكريه امريكيه اكثر مما حصل في
الايام الاخيره لكن هذا التواجد او هذا
الانتشار الاخير يدل اولا على فشل اداره
بايدن في تحقيق سياساتها كلنا نتذكر ان
بايدن كان قد وعد بوضع حلول لملفات منطقه
الشرق الاوسط للاتجاه الى الصين وما الى
ذلك ونحن اليوم نشاهد انه لم يحقق شيئا في
الصين لم يترك عدا الى المنطقه وضمن فشله
طبعا في ملف الازمه الاوكرانيه النقطه
الثانيه هذا يدل على يعني يعد ابراز عضلات
اكثر من ان يكون حقيقيا على الارض
بسبب فشل الاداره الامريكيه ايضا في فرض
شروطها على الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
لاسيما في المفاوضات التي جرت حول بعض
الملفات ومنها موضوع اطلاق سراح المعتقلين
لذلك انا لا اتصور ان
شيئا مهما حصل في المنطقه لا سيما ان
الاداره الامريكيه اذا عدنا الى التاريخ
كما قال ضيفك الامريكي نجد ان الاداره
الامريكيه لم تحرك ساكنا سابقا في بعض ما
حصل مثلا على سبيل المثال السفينه التي
كانت قد سرقت النفط الايراني وتم العثور
عليها في مياه الخليج الفارسي حينما حاولت
ايران او اتجهت ايران نحو السيطره عليها
استنجدت بالقوات الحربيه الامريكيه لتاتي
هذه القوات وتنجد القراصنه البحريين لكن
ايران استطاعت ان تستولي على ذلك ايضا في
بعض الحالات التي حصلت بعض العمليات
العسكريه في منطقه في هذه المنطقه لم نشهد
ان الاداره الامريكيه حركت ساكنا لذلك لا
اتصور ان
احدا سيصدق ان الاداره الامريكيه او القوى
والقوات العسكريه الامريكيه في هذه
المنطقه ستحقق الامن بل انها تخل بالامن
الاقليمي لاسيما ان كل المنطقه متجهه يعني
لا وجودا لنزاع او في في هذه المنطقه انما
كل المنطقه
طيب اعود
الادمرال انت كقائد عسكري وقائد سابق
للقاده الوسطى الامريكيه عندما ترسل
البحريه الامريكيه سفينه انزال وسفينه
تحمل طائرات الى هذه المنطقه المتوتره
اصلا ما الذي يعني هذا بالمفهوم العسكري
هل يؤشر الى شيء وما احتماليه حصول صدام
مباشر بين الحرس الثوري الايراني والقوات
الامريكيه المتواجده هناك
في البدايه اود ان اعود لاقول انني لا
اتفق ابدا مع
الضيف من طهران ولكن القوات البحريه اجابه
عن سؤالكم هي مرنه وهي جاهزه للرد وهي
تثبت ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مهتمه
في المنطقه
ولا نتحدث عن
فشلند دبلوماسي بل نتحدث عن رد على
التصرفات الايرانيه في تلك المنطقه وهي
غير مناسبه وهي لا تندرج في سياق القوانين
الدوليه ولذلك التواجد العسكري هو من ضمن
البعثه الامريكيه التي تتحرك في كل انحاء
العالم لتثبت ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لديها ما يكفي من عزم والرساله
هي انها تهتم بمنطقه الخليج
وتود ان تتاكد من امني واستقرار الخليج في
مواجهه
الانشطه الايرانيه المزعزعه للاستقرار
وبالتالي هذه القوات تتحرك
والهدف منها ارسال رساله ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تهتم بشان هذه المنطقه
وتود ان تحافظ على الوضع الامني
لتامين
لمحمد مهدي شريعه انداري ما الانعكاسات
المحتمله على ملفات شائكه بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وايران خاصه الملف
النووي الايراني هل ترى رابطا ما بين
زياده الضغط العسكري على ايران في هذه
المنطقه
والمفاوضات الدبلوماسيه فيما يتعلق بالملف
النووي الايراني
اولا انا لا اتصور انا طيران تعد ذلك ضغطا
عسكريا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تعرف
جيدا القدرات العسكريه الايرانيه ومدى
اراده ايران على الرد على اي
اعتداء او تهديد ياتي من الخارج هذه
النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه لا ارتباط
لا وجود لارتباط بين هذين المسارين الملف
النووي المفاوضات حول الماء في النووي
توقفت بسبب
غطرسه الجانب الامريكي الذي كان يريد ان
يفرض شروطه على ايران وايران لم تقبل بذلك
لم تقبل بانصاف الحلول لم تقبل بحل مؤقت
لم تقبل بادخال الملفات الاخرى في الملف
النووي ولذلك توقفت
المفاوضات متى ما عادت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى التزاماتها وفق الاتفاق انه
يمكن ان تعود هذه المفاوضات الى مساراتها
الطبيعيه لذلك لا اتصور ان هناك نعم شكرا
لك ما محمد مهدي شريعه في طهران والادمره
الوليام فلن في مونتانا الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الاوكراني
القوات الروسيه استهدفت بصاروخين مبنى
سكنيا في مدينه بوكرفسكي بمقاطعه دونيسك
وتظهر صور اضرارا ماديه كبيره لحقت
بالمنطقه والمبدا المستهدف كما هرعت طواقم
الاسعاف الى المكان لاخلاء عدد من الجرحى
ونقلهم بالمستشفيات تلقي العلاج اللازم
جانبها اعلنت موسكو اسقاط مسيرتين
اوكرانيتين داخل اراضيها وبانها حققت
مكاسب ميدانيه في مقاطعه دونيسك في حين
اكدت كييف تعرض مقاطع تيخار كيف وخيرسون
لقسم روسي اسفر عن سقوط قتلى وجرحى
من جديد تؤكد السلطات الروسيه اسقاطها
للمسيرات اوكرانيات داخل عمق اراضيها اذ
اعلن حاكما مقاطعتي كالوجا اسقاط مسيرات
كانت تحلق في سماء المقاطعتين المبادره في
دنيا جنوب الشرقي اوكرانيا كانت من جانب
القوات الروسيه التي تقول ان مدفعيتها
دمرت مقرا للقوات الاوكرانيه في محيط
مدينه الايمان وان وحداتها سيطرت على سبعه
مواقع اوكرانيه ودمرت سريه مشاه في منطقه
اوتشان القوات الروسيه اكدت كذلك تمكنها
من صد هجوم للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه
كليشييفيكا باتجاه باخموت وانها ردت
بمهاجمه مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه في
المنطقه نفسها مدينه كوبيانز في مقاطعه
شمال شرقي اوكرانيا كانت هدفا لقصف الروسي
اذ افادت السلطات المحليه هناك ان القصف
اسفر عن مقتل شخصين وا ثلاثه اخرين على
الجبهه البحريه تبدو كييف مصره على تصعيد
هجماتها ضد سفن موسكو في البحر الاسود اذ
توعد الرئيس الاوكراني
بان تصبح روسيا دوله بلا سفن في حال
مواصله استهداف موانئ بلاده وسفنها وتقول
البحريه الاوكرانيه ان ثلاثه سفن روسيه
معاديه تجوب البحر الاسود ما يفتح باب
التوقعات امام هجمات مماثله لما وقع في
اليومين الماضيين في حين تقول قياده
عمليات المنطقه الجنوبيه في الجيش
الاوكراني ان البحريه الروسيات تغير
تكتيكاتها العسكريه بشكل مستمر وانها تحضر
لتنفيذ ضربات صاروخيه من البحر الاسود
خلال الساعات 48 القادمه
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع
يدوي انفجارات متتاليه بالقرب من المدينه
الرياضيه الجنوبيه الخرطوم جانب اخر قالت
لجانو مقاومه منطقه ابروف في احياء ام
دربان القديمه من المنطقه تتحولت الى مسرح
عمليه عسكريه بين الجيش السوداني وقوه
الدعم السريع واكدت ان قوه الجيش والدعم
السريع في المنطقه طلبت من السكان اخلاء
منازلهم باعتبار ابروف منطقه عمليات وكان
الجيش السوداني قد اطلق صباح اليوم قذائف
مدفعيه من شمال ام درمان باتجاه مواقع
لقوات الدعم السريع كما شنت طائرات الجيش
غارات على مواقع للدعم في الخرطوم بحري
وقصفت القصر الجمهوريه الذي تسيطر عليه
قوات الدعم وسط العاصمه
في توضيح لمكان تركز المعارك والاشتباكات
في الساعات الاخيره بالعاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم تشهد احياء ام درمان مواجهات بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع فقد افاد مراسل
الجزيره بان قوه من الجيش تمركزت شمال حي
ابروف وغربه بينما بقيت المناطق جنوب وشرق
ابروف تحت سيطره الدعم السريع يبعد الحي
قرابه كيلو متر واحد عن جسر شمبات الذي
تسيطر عليه قوه الدعم السريع ويعتبر
منفذها الاوحد في عمليه نقل الجنود
والمعدات والعتاد
[موسيقى]
بدات الحكومه البريطانيه نقل اول دفعه من
طالبي اللجوء الى احدى العوامات الراسيه
في جنوب البلاد ان خطه لنقل طالبي اللجوء
الى عوامات وقواعد عسكريه سابقه
اصبحت الشائعه حقيقه حكومه بريطانيا تسوق
المحتمين بها الى هذا المكان
بارجه بيبي ستوكهولم ستصبح مكان اقامه
طالبي اللجوء ريثما يفحصهم القضاء فحصا
500 رجل ممن عبروا البحار بحثا عن الامان
اخرجوا من الفنادق وحشروا داخل هذه
البارجه التي قال مختصون انها غير امنه
حكومه بريطانيا كانت قد قررت بعد جدال
طويل ابعاد المحتمل بها الى رواندا لكن
المحكمه العليا الغت ذلك القرار عادت لندن
وقررت ارسال ضيوفها الى البوارج والقواعد
العسكريه الخارجه عن الخدمه محتجه بان
استضافتهم في الفنادق كلفتها اكثر من
مليارين دولار مسؤول من العفو الدوليه قال
ان لندن لم تترك اي خطوه تشعر اللاجئين
بانهم غير مرحب بهم وغيره امنين في
اراضيها الا واتخذتها كما قارن البارجه
بسجون العصر الفيكتوري جازما انها لا
تناسب من خرجوا من ديارهم هربا من
الاضطهاد والارهاب
المسؤوله بوزاره الداخليه البريطانيه
علقت على امتعاض الحقوقيين من الخطوه بان
على الداخلين الى بريطانيا بطرق غير
قانونيه الا يتوقع الاقامه في فنادق خمس
نجوم
طلب الينا من لندن
محرره الشؤون الداخليه في صحيفه
كيف ترون هذا الاجراء من الحكومه
البريطانيه
المره الاولى التي نشهد فيها شيئا مماثلا
في المملكه المتحده هي تجربه على مستوى
واسع نطاق وهي تسبب تكاليف متعدده باضافه
الى بعد السياسي لانه اذا ما لم تاتي
بالفائده سوف يؤدي ذلك الى ضرر هل يعني
هذا بالضروره بان هذا الاجراء هو بدايه
لحل ازمه اللجوء في بريطانيا
الحكومه البريطانيه تامل ان هذا الاجراء
سوف يساعد ولكن ما من ادله او بحوث تدعم
هذا الراي اذن تعتقد الحكومه ان هذه
البارجه والقواعد العسكريه اذا ما استخدمت
سوف ترضع طالبي اللجوء من ان ياتوا الى
بريطانيا ولكن النتيجه قد تكون عكسيه ما
الذي قد يواجهه رئيس الحكومه ريشيسونيك مع
تعاظم هذه الازمه ازمه اللجوء في بريطانيا
مستقبلا
مجلس الوزراء
اعلن انه من بين الوعود الخمس الاساسيه
للشعب البريطاني سوف يكون منع المهاجرين
غير نظاميين عبر القناه الانجليزيه
والاعداد لا تزال ترتفع ويبدو ان السياسات
الحكوميه لم تؤتي اكلها ولذلك يبدو ان
رئيس مجلس الوزراء سوف يواجه صعوبات على
مستوى الناخبين البريطانيين وعلى مستوى
حزمه وما التحديات التي تواجهه للحد من
هذه المعضله داخليا باغتضاد لو سمحتي
الراهنه السياسات الحكوميه تسعى الى ردعي
قدوم
طالبي اللجوء ولكن لا تؤمن الحكومه خيارات
اخرى هناك طرق امنه محدوده جدا للقدوم الى
المملكه المتحده وبالتالي الا في حال
اتيحت هذه القنوات الاخرى سوف يستمر الناس
بالعبور بهذه الطريقه وهذا هو التحدي شكرا
لك في لندن
تزامنا مع هذه الخطوه خرج العشرات من
طالبي اللجوء في مظاهره شمال غربي لندن
للاحتجاج على سياسه الحكومه البريطانيه في
التعامل مع طلبات لجوهم وظروف جوائهم
هذه مظاهره لطالبي اللجوء كما ترون تجمع
العشرات منهم وايضا معهم عدد من مؤيدي
حقوق اللاجئين تجمعوا هنا في شمال لندن
للاحتجاج على سياسه الحكومه البريطانيه
سواء في عمليه ايواءهم في الفنادق كثيرون
منهم تسلموا اختارات من الحكومه بان عليهم
ان يقيموا اكثر من شخص في غرفه واحده وهم
يعتبرون
انها تمتد عاده الى قرابه العامين فهذا
نوع من التعسف من قبل الحكومه ويعترضون
ايضا على توجه الحكومه البريطانيه لنقل
طالبي اللجوء من الفنادق التي انزلته بها
الى قواعد عسكريه سابقه وعوامات هذه
التظاهرات تتزامن بالفعل مع بدء الحكومه
في نقل طالبي عدد منهم الدفعه الاولى
نقلت اليوم الى عوامه بيبي
الروسيه في جنوب لندن في عفوا في جنوب
بريطانيا في ميناء
هذه التظاهرات تتزامن كذلك مع اعلان
الحكومه البريطانيه مضاعفه الغرامات ثلاثه
اضعاف للغرامات المفروضه على اي شخص يساعد
المهاجرين غير النظاميين سواء عن طريق
تاجير مسكن لهم او عن طريق توفير عمل لهم
لان هذا امر يخالف القانون البريطاني
الحكومه من جانبها تقول ان عليها ان تنقل
طالبي اللجوء الى العوامات والقواعد
العسكريه لانه ليس من العدل بالنسبه لدفع
الضرائب البريطاني ان يتكلف فاتوره
اقامتهم التي تتكلم عاده سته ملايين جنيه
استرليني يوميا كما تقول الحكومه اسعد
الله الصاوي الجزيره لندن
توتر في بحر جنوب الصين بعد احتكاك بين
الاسطولين الصيني والفلبيني تتهموا واشنطن
بتغذيه الخلافات والسؤال هل اصبحت عين
امريكا على الفلبين ولماذا تقع الفلبين في
جنوب شرق اسيا غرب المحيط الهادئ هي عباره
عن ارخبيل مكون من الاف الجزر تحده تايوان
الى الشمال عبر مضيق لوزون وفيتنام الى
الغرب عبر بحر جنوب الصين الفلبين هي
الاقرب الى تايوان من بين دول جنوب شرق
اسيا من جهه الجنوب الغربي وهي الاقرب الى
اليابان ايضا فضلا عن بحر غرب الفلبين
المتصل ببحر جنوب الصين اي تحرك للقطع
البحريه والغواصات الصينيه باتجاه غرب
المحيط الهادئ من جزيره هاينان الصينيه
حيث تتمركز قياده احد ثلاثه اساطيل صينيه
يحتاج الى المرور عبر مضيق لوزون شمالي
الفلبين الواقع الى الجنوب من تايوان ايضا
ماذا عن تقارب واشنطن مانيلا ابريل الماضي
شهد تدريبات عسكريه هي الاكبر بين
الولايات المتحده والفلبين في بحر جنوب
الصين في ظل وجود عسكري صيني متزايد
بالمنطقه شارك في المناورات نحو ثمانيه
عشر الف جندي تضمنت لاول مره تدريبات
بالذخيره الحيه هبوط مروحيات عسكريه على
جزيره لوزون الفلبينيه على بعد 300 كم من
تايوان في ابريل ايضا وضعت الفلبين اربع
قواعد عسكريه اضافيه تحت التصرف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من بينها قاعده بحريه
بل قاعده بحريه لا تبعد عن تايوان مما
اثار غضب بجين واخرى قرب بحري جنوب الصين
يربط الولايات المتحده والفلبين تحالف
امني منذ عقود يشمل معاهده للدفاع
المتبادل واتفاق التعاون الدفاعي المعزز
الموقع عام 2014
ويسمح للقوات الامريكيه بالوجود في خمس
قواعد فلبينيه بما فيها تلك القريبه من
مياه متنازع عليها والسؤال الذي يطرح نفسه
كيف ترى الولايات المتحده الفلبين على
مواقع حكوميه رسميه تقول الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الفلبين ذات موقع استراتيجي
في منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وذات
اهميه للمصالح الامريكيه وحليف رئيسي خارج
النيتو الفلبين ايضا تحتاج الى الولايات
المتحده لاحداث توازن في مقابل تزايد
النفوذ العسكري الصيني في بحر جنوب الصين
خاصه في ظل التوتر الصيني الفلبيني في بحر
جنوب الصين منذ تسلمه الرئاسه العام
الماضي حل الرئيس الفلسطيني فرديناند
ماركوس الابن ضيفا في البيت الابيض مرتين
ورحب به الرئيس الامري قائلا لا يمكنني
تصور حليف افضل منك يتوجه بالحديث طبعا
الى رئيس الفلبين ماركوس وفي رساله لافته
قال في وقت سابق لن تسمح باستخدام الفلبين
منطلقا لاي عمل عسكري ما يهمنا هو السلام
لكن لن نسمح للصين بالسيطره على حقوق
الفلبين في بحارها في ظل اجواء الاستقطاب
الصين على الخط فخلال زيارته الى بيجين في
يناير الماضي تلقى الرئيس الفلبيني تعهدات
صينيه باستثمارات تصل الى 22 مليار دولار
ينضم الينا من واشنطن السيد ديفيد سيدني
نائب رئيس البعثه الامريكي السابق بجين
ونائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق
لشؤون اسيا سيد ديفيد ما الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه التي تشكرها الفلبين بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه في هذه
المنطقه
هي حليف استراتيجيه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولكل الدول في تلك المنطقه بما
في ذلك استراليا اليابان الهند وكوريا
وبالتالي لا نتحدث فقط عن مواجهه بين
الولايات المتحده والصين بل نتحدث عن
منطقه فيها كل البلدان الاخرى المحيطه
بالصين في مواجهتها
هذا التقارب الصيني الامريكي المتزايد
وخاصه على الصعيد العسكري اين يضع الفلبين
في هذه الخارطه الواسعه في هذه المنطقه
خاصه بوجود دوله عظمى كبرى مثل الصين
على مر
السنوات الثلاثين الى اربعين الماضيه
توسعت الصين في مزاعمها في بحر جنوب الصين
ونتحدث في البدايه عن
كيلومترات بدات محدوده وبعد ذلك ارادت
الصين ان تبسط السيطراتها على
المياه التي تبتعد فقط عشرات الكيلومترات
عن شواطئ الفلبين
الصيادون من الفلبين يصطادون في تلك
المنطقه لمئات السنوات وبالتالي هي جزء من
الاراضي الفلبينيه والصين تضغط على
الفلبين لذلك بدات الفلبين بالتواصل مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لاعاده نسج
وتعزيز العلاقات الدفاعيه التي تراجعت قبل
30 عاما عندما اغلقت الفلبين القاعده
البحريه ولكن في خلال السنوات الماضيه
عززت الفلبين تعاونها العسكري مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بما في ذلك دوريات
مشتركه والولايات المتحده والفلبين لديهما
كما اشرتم معاهده للدفاع المشترك اذا ما
تعرضت الفلبين لاي هجوم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تدافع عن الفلبين ولذلك نتحدث
عن وضع في غايه الخطوره لان الفلبين هناك
لو كانت لوحدها سوف تكون ضعيفه في مواجهه
الصين لان قدراتها محدوده ولكن بدعم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واستراليا
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه ودول اخرى
باستطاعه الفلبين ان تواجه الصين والشعب
الفلبيني موحد
بالقول انه غير مستعد لكي تسيطر الصين على
حقوقه ولكن يبدو ان هذا يزيد التوتر بين
الصين والفلبين وتابعنا ما حصل قبل ايام
في بحر جنوب الصين بتق ديركم كيف يمكن ان
يكون رد الفعل الصيني على زياده التعاون
العسكري بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والفلبين
الصينيون الان في مزاج قوميا قوي الرئيس
اوضح هذه النقطه وانا السياسه القوميه هي
في صلب سياساتها الصين مقابل كل دول
العالم وبالتالي الصين لا تتراجع وهذا
البسط للنفوذ في بحر جنوب الصين بدا من
خلال السياسات الحكوميه التي بدات في
بيجين واتجهت تايوان منذ تسع سنوات
الحكومه الصينيه ليس لديها خيارات في هذه
المره لان الشعب الصيني سوف يرى ان اي
تراجع من قبل الصين هو هزيمه والرئيس
الصيني لا يمكنه ان يقبل بذلك وخصوصا وان
الصين تواجه مشاكل اقتصاديه وكيف ترى
مستقبل العلاقه في ظل هذا التوتر الحاصل
مستقبل العلاقه ما بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
والفلبين مع التواجد الصيني الكبير في هذه
المنطقه
لسوء الحظ يبدو وكان التوترات سوف تستمر
لفتره طويله وسوف يشكل ذلك تحديا كبيرا
للدول في المنطقه ان تتفادى المواجهه
العسكريه الفلبين والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على استعدادا للتراجع والصين
كذلك بالاضافه الى الدول الدول الاسيان في
تلك المنطقه وهي حاولت ان تصل الى نوعا من
مدونه السلوك بالنسبه الى كيفيه التصرف في
بحر جنوب الصين هذا لا يكفي ولا يؤدي الى
خفض التصعيد ويبدو ان التوتر بالتالي سوف
يرتفع في تلك المنطقه وهناك احتمال ان
الدول الاسيان سوف تتمكن من اتخاذ خطوات
لخفض التصعيد ولكن ذلك يتضمن الكثير من
العمل الدبلوماسي الذي لم نراه بعد شكرا
نائب رئيس البعثه الامريكيه السابقين
ونائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق
لشؤون اسيا في واشنطن شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
سواحل صفاقس التونسيه بوسط شرق البلاد لقي
احد عشر من طالبي اللجوء مصرعهم بينما
اعتبر نحو 44 اخرين في عداد المفقودين
اثراء غرق مركب كان يقل سبعه وخمسين من
طالبي اللجوء انطلقوا من صفاقس في اتجاه
السواحل الاوروبيه خفوا السواحل الايطاليه
انقض عدد من طالبي اللجوء بعد غرق قاربهم
قرب سواحل لمبيدوزا بينما اعتبر نحو 30
اخرين في عداد المفقودين بالتزامن البحريه
المغربيه تنتشر خمسه من طالبي اللجوء
وتنقذ نحو 200 بعد انقلاب قاربهم قبله
اقليم الصحراء وفي بريطانيا الحكومه تقرر
مضاعفه الغرامات المفروضه على من يقدم
عملا او يؤجر مسكنا لاي طالب لجوء غير
نظامي بنسبه 300
معضله من ضاقت عليهم اوطانهم وضاقت عليهم
ايضا الاوطان البدين الماموله نامل في
حياه افضل للجميع حياه الحصاد الى اللقاء
بامر الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]